whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Washington DC
officials who are mulling a Bloomberg
style soda ban and Florida's Fish and
Wildlife Conservation Commission which
put the kibosh on alligator pool parties
Antion top having an alligator for a
swimming pool party the rescued baby
Gators would get taped up and kids who'd
get a safety lesson but that didn't
satisfy officials who halted the newly
created alternative to those creepy
chuck-e-cheese parties but there can be
only one man of the month in this time
it's los angeles city councilman paul
koretz today the city council approved a
new law that bans stores from selling
dogs and cats unless the animals are
rescued or come from a shelter the
ordinance was spearheaded by Koretz
wants less business for pet readers and
more pet adoptions and we all want
animals to have homes the pet store
owners who could face misdemeanor
charges for violations so what about
freedom of choice this country is
founded on choice and people should have
a choice to unless it goes bankrupt
first the cities of double-digit
unemployment and a deadly slow emergency
response system is poised to become the
largest jurisdiction to crack down on
pet sales check back next month for more
examples of busybodies minded your own
business